did you know the terraform has its own  language called HCL are you wondering  what the HL syntax looks like learn more  in this short  terraform uses the hashicorp  configuration language or HCL to Define  resources create dependencies and Define  what data will be fetched  let's explore each of the components of  HCL syntax  blocks represent a collection of code of  a certain type examples include  resources variables and outputs  arguments are used to assign a value to  an identifier  identifiers are names of an argument  block type or any terraform-specific  construct  Expressions can be used to compute a  value to assign to an identifier  terraform also supports more complex  expressions like conditions and loops  are you ready to learn more click on the  three dots and then click on the link in  the description box to enroll in the  getting started with terraform for  Google Cloud course see you there